uh okay we are continuing to
learn about who the individuals
involved in the january 6th trump riot
are
and who they were and what areas of
society and industry they came from
now i already told you it was either
last week or maybe the week before
that members of the military current and
former
uh were dramatically over represented
among the trump rioters on january 6th
something like
14 of those arrested uh
were either former or current members of
the military that's very concerning and
we now have another
individual story 14 is is a a general
number
we now have an individual story that's
even more horrifying uh according to
time a man who authorities say is a
leader of the far-right
oath keepers militia group and helped to
organize
other extremists in their participation
in the january 6th
trump riots number one held a top secret
security clearance for decades
and number two previously worked for the
fbi according to his own attorney now
you might be wondering
why is this guy's own attorney saying
these things it
it raises more concerns it should make
us horrified that that was the position
this guy held
well his attorney is raising these
issues to justify
that he should be out on bail and that
he's super trustworthy and you don't
have to worry about him the man's name
is thomas caldwell
authorities believe that he has a
leadership role in this extremist group
called the oath keepers
he was fbi section chief between 2009
and 2010. this is not any fbi person
would be a real red flag
in terms of their participation but this
was not a nobody to the extent that
there are nobodies in the fbi
this was a section chief from 2009 to
2010.
previously he was in the navy again we
talked about the over-representation of
members of the military among the trump
rioters
and his lawyer thomas ploufcian
wrote in a motion saying listen look at
this guy's cred
you can safely release him as he awaits
trial
because he was in the navy and he was
fbi section chief and um
the uh reason why you can trust him
is he had this top secret security
clearance and he worked for the fbi
and he had a consulting firm that did
work for the us government this guy's
trustworthy
and of course as many of us learn more
and more about the individuals
involved in the january 6 riot we are
horrified we are horrified about wow i
mean listen people can change in 11
years right this guy was fbi section
chief from 2009 to 2010
in 2021 he finds himself uh
participating
in the trump riot um many of us would
logically be led to ask did the fbi
miss signs about this guy back
in 2009 and the counter argument will be
well no the fbi could have done its job
at vetting in 2009 there really might
have been nothing there then
and something happened since then that
ended up radicalizing this guy to the
point where
he's part of the oath keepers this
right-wing militia group and he's
participating in the january six riots
but
we all should be asking um who else is
in there now
who who's in the military now who's in
the fbi now
that has these same ideas the same
ideology the same
allegiances for lack of a better term as
this guy and we just don't know about
that yet that is a very very uh
concerning element of this and the truth
is we should be horrified
that uh these are the individuals that
not just participated but allegedly
were organizers of the trump riot this
is essentially a terrorist this is
someone who
organized others to attempt
a violent insurrection because they
didn't like
the results of a democratically held
election there's really no other way to
define what these folks are
and um the the other kind of a few
people wrote to me and they said you
know it's interesting that
this guy caldwell is now uh he's he's
disabled legally
he uh is on disability and he's received
he's on the government dole so to speak
and uh pointing out people were pointing
out two things one is less interesting
to me some folks wrote to me and said
david this guy
clearly is not disabled because he was
able
to participate in the riots i think that
that's the wrong angle to go at i think
it starts to get into these sometimes
prejudicial or discriminatory things
about what is a
disabled person look like and i don't
like that i'm not going to go in that
direction
um the part that is more interesting
from a political standpoint is that a
lot of anti-government extremists
are sometimes completely dependent on
the government and
that reminds me of you know keep the
government out of my medicare
sort of stuff where do people not
understand where their
uh benefits are coming from or do they
not care
are they blinded by ideology is it some
combination of all of all of the above
that's more interesting to me
evaluating whether someone is or isn't
truly disabled based on whether they're
at the riot
i'm not going to get involved in that
but the numbers continue to be
concerning
14 of those arrested former or current
military
we now are learning more about
individuals who were
relatively high ranking folks uh within
agencies up to and including the fbi
this should horrify
all of us we know that the military has
been looking at white supremacy within
its ranks for some time
but what is the fbi doing what is the
cia doing how many of these folks
are in there within the system and what
does that mean
going forward when we think about
federal responses to events like this
which
hopefully will be very infrequent but
but history tells us
uh it is bound to happen again at some
point and how prepared will we actually
be
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at d pacman we'll be back
and uh much to discuss today if you are
anything like me you probably aren't
thrilled with the idea of going into a
doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steadymd
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which
doctor is right for you i took their
quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video